nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une
situation que je dirais catastrophique
le point de rupture pour minou est
atteint aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons plus
assurer nos missions de soins dans des
conditions acceptables ni pour les
patients ni pour les soignants la
sécurité des patients est
quotidiennement mises à mal
les exemples ne manquent pas les
exemples de perte de chance sont
vraiment très nombreux si vous voulez je
peux vous donner des exemples précis
tout à l'heure mais je n'aurai pas le
temps maintenant ils sont clairement
liés à un manque de lits et de personnel
sur tout le territoire un manque qui ne
cesse de s'aggraver et qui est inquiète
à juste titre les hôpitaux les élus et
les journalistes comme vous pouvez le
constater dans la revue de presse
régionale et nationale que donc on va
vous remettre à la fin de cette audition
qui concerne l'hôpital public la réalité
est qu'aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus
capables de garantir la prise en charge
des situations médicales courante selon
nous quelles sont les causes de la
situation actuelle
premièrement le couple mortelle de la
facturation à l'acte la t2a et de
l'ondam qui se résument pour moi à faire
toujours plus avec toujours moins pour
les soignants de terrain la facturation
à l'acte associé à l' enveloppe fermée
de l'ondam est responsable de la
situation actuelle cette tarification
n'est pas adapté pour prendre en charge
les patients avec les malades chroniques
avec des polypathologies c'est à dire
des patients qui ont plusieurs
pathologies des patients qui sont
vieillissants dans la prise en charge et
donc délaissé par le secteur privé
lucratif
la quasi-totalité de la pédiatrie
hospitalière par exemple est assuré par
le secteur public qu'est ce qu'elle
n'est pas car parce qu'elle n'est pas
rémunératrices
le financement de l'hôpital public
n'étant plus jamais en rapport avec les
besoins réels de santé d'un territoire
et de ses dépenses réelles il en résulte
une nécessité d'économies or les
économies se font majoritairement sur le
personnel soignant qui reste la
principale variable d'ajustement
alors que des études scientifiques ont
démontré que la mortalité des patients
augmente dès qu'une infirmière doit
s'occuper de plus de six patients de
jour ou de nuit dans un service
d'hospitalisation standard dans nos
hôpitaux il n'est pas rare qu'une
infirme heures doivent s'occuper de
seize patients en journée voire 24 la
nuit je vous remets très aussi l'article
scientifique sur lequel je me base pour
donner un ces chiffres puisque dans ces
conditions la sécurité des patients ne
peut plus être assuré on assiste
aujourd'hui à des départs massifs de
soignants écoeurés par leurs conditions
d'exercice
deuxième problème pour nous c'est la
prise de décisions déconnecté des
besoins du terrain le fonctionnement de
l'hôpital est basée sur une prise de
décision exclusive par un non soignants
le directeur en lien direct avec l'état
notre impression est que les
considérations financières priment
toujours sur celle de la bonne prise en
charge des malades malgré des conditions
de travail difficiles les soignants en
jusque là tenus sur quoi sur la fierté
de participer à la santé publique et la
reconnaissance lié à celle ci avec le
message que les questions financières
sont plus importantes que le bon soin
cette motivation disparaît et le
personnel par les médecins s'installent
en libéral sans permanence de soins les
paramédics aux parts soit vers le
libéral où ils sont maîtres de leur
temps et de leur pratique soit change
carrément de métier enfin troisièmement
les soignants parts en raison d'un
espoir déçu les difficultés de l'hôpital
public sont antérieurs à la crise qu
vide en revanche la crise qu vide à
créer l'illusion que les
dysfonctionnements avaient été entendus
nous avions l'espoir qu'enfin nous
pourrions retrouver notre métier selon
les principes et valeurs qui nous l'ont
fait choisir les ségur n'a pourtant
apporté qu'une réponse partielle
financière est insuffisante sur un
problème beaucoup plus général
donc notre avis quelles sont les
solutions l'urgence absolue est de
maintenir le personnel soignant
actuellement présent faut absolument
tout faire pour qu'il parte qui ne
partent pas plus tôt ensuite il faudra
donner envie aux étudiants de rejoindre
l'hôpital puis reconquérir les
démissionnaires le seul moyen pour y
arriver est de rassurer les
professionnels par des actes forts
fonctionner uniquement avec des équipes
en nombre reconnaître les compétences
spécifiques des soignants en les
laissant travailler dans les équipes
correspondant à leurs compétences
définir absolument un ratio soignants
patients minimale sanctuariser un
planning stable et décent refuser les
alternances d'horaires jour et de nuit
assurer la formation des soignants
remplacer systématiquement et à 100% les
absences pour congé maternité maladie
formation ce qui veut dire que les
équipes devraient être dimensionnée à
120 % de l'effectif cible pour permettre
maternité formation maladie et vacances
assurer un salaire décent prenant en
compte la pénibilité notamment pour les
périodes de travail qui empiète sur la
vie personnelle week end et je nuis
meilleure valorisation salle orale
salariale des personnels ayant de
l'expérience
l'expérience est précieuse pour garantir
la prise en charge et la qualité des la
sécurité des soins ou des formations
spécifiques pour
terminer j'aimerais attirer l'attention
de la commission sur le fait que
l'hôpital public est l'épiné dorsale de
notre système de santé un système de
santé qui est enviée ou qui a était
enviée jusqu'à peu encore du monde
entier si l'hôpital public s'effondre
tout le système de santé s'effondre le
sauver et donc simplement un acte
républicain je vous remercie
[Musique]